- Welcome to everybody.
And I'm sorry we're
so tightly packed.
But I'm also gratified
that we have so many people
to show up for this.
So my name is John Huth.
And I am a Radcliffe
Ventures faculty member.
So that means that I help put
together programs at Radcliffe.
My main focus is
on the sciences.
And this year we, had a science
symposium in October on oceans,
and then have a series of
themed lectures associated
with oceans.
And this the last in the series.
This is close to my last
official act as a Radcliffe
Ventures faculty.
And I will just note that
Alissa Goodman over here
will be taking my role.
So you'll see her at the podium
in future Radcliffe events.
So on to the main event--
so a lot of cultures
use waves in some way
as a navigational
aid on the oceans.
This is fairly well-known.
But as far as I'm aware, the
use of waves in navigation
really reached its pinnacle
in the Marshall Islands.
And it fascinates people.
It fascinated me.
When you look at some
of the artifacts that
are used to teach people,
you're wondering, what is that?
And what does that mean.
And so on.
And so the fascination
is understandable.
And trying to tease apart what
the Marshallese navigators did,
how they were taught, and how
they conceptualized using waves
on the open ocean
really requires
an interdisciplinary approach.
And I was introduced
to this, and started
collaborating with one of the
first of our speakers, Joe
Genz, who is an anthropologist
at the University of Hawaii.
And he introduced
me to Alson Kelen,
who runs an outfit called
Canoe's of the Marshall
Islands, and spent
quite a bit of time
understanding the traditions
of canoe building.
And he'll talk about his
enterprise with that.
And he acted as our host
and navigator on a voyage
that we took.
And Gerbrant van Vledder, who
is from the University of Delft,
and he specializes in the
numerical simulations of waves.
So we all assembled together
in the Marshall Islands,
in Majuro in the capitol, talked
to one of the last surviving
indigenous navigators, who
unfortunately passed away
in January.
And then we took
this trip from Majuro
to a neighboring atoll, Aur,
and back again and documented as
best we could to try to
understand the traditions.
And Monday and Tuesday,
we held a workshop
to go over our
findings, because it
took a while to crunch the
numbers, and to think about it.
And so now, we met
yesterday and today,
talked about what we saw.
Some new information
came out as we
started talking to each other.
We're going to write a paper.
And we have some ideas about a
forthcoming journey that we're
going to make, where we're
going to try to systematize
some of our findings.
OK, so thank you for being here.
And I turn it over Joe.
All right, hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Joe Genz.
And as John said, I'm
an assistant professor
at the University
of Hawaii at Hilo.
And I've been connected to
this project since about 2001
when I first started
as a graduate student.
So what I'm going to try
to do today is just back
up a little bit
and talk about some
of the context that started the
development of this project,
that will then lead into
what Alson, and Gerbrant,
and John will talk about.
So the first thing
to note is that we're
talking about wave piloting.
But this is really a
system of navigation.
And, in particular,
this is practiced,
and has been practiced
historically,
in a few places in
the Pacific Islands,
what the residents of
that group in the world
refers to as Oceania.
And anthropologists have
been particularly drawn
to this system of voyaging,
which really encompasses
a whole range of things,
from canoe building,
to sailing, to astronomy, to
weather forecasting, and then
the kind of ultimate domain
of knowledge of navigation.
The image that we're
showing up here
today is the picture from
our canoe voyage in 2015.
And the other image
from the Bishop Museum
in Honolulu from 1883,
to me, represents
a very strong
continuity of knowledge
in this particular case.
And so anthropologists have
looked at canoe voyaging
in a lot of different ways.
Among them is looking at how
the canoes and the systems
of navigation could have allowed
for the two-way intentional
settlement to the Pacific, the
discovery, the exploration,
and the intentional
colonization of those islands.
That's been a
large focus of what
anthropology has looked at.
But in order to
understand that, to think
about that prehistoric
past, anthropologists
have also needed to know
a lot about the knowledge
systems themselves.
And so if we look back in time,
these voyaging traditions that
span the breadth of
Oceania, some of them
decline very dramatically
several hundred of years ago.
Some places like
Hawaii, they basically
had to reinvent
and kind of relearn
their system of navigating
that basically died out
about 200 years ago.
On another kind of
spectrum of voyaging,
in places like Satawal, which
is in the contemporary nation
state of the Federated
States of Micronesia,
they practice voyaging
on a daily basis.
It is part of the
fabric of their lives.
And somewhere in the
middle between those two
in the spectrum of voyaging
is the Marshall Islands,
where there are traditions that
are intact, to some degree.
But there's also been
a very large decline.
So this is a map of
the Marshall Islands.
It's a very large region.
It encompasses 29 coral atolls
and five low-lying coral
islands that spread in an area
of about 750,000 square miles.
So it's a very large area.
When you look at
language distributions,
historical observations,
archaeological evidence,
it's very clear
that the Marshallese
had very strong voyaging
capabilities, as evidenced
by this historic map
that was produced
by a German explorer
named [INAUDIBLE] who
was part of a Russian
expedition, who
worked with navigators
to produce this map based
on their geographical knowledge.
And another way
that we know this
is through the historically
documented stick charts.
These were largely
collected and sent
to museums around
the world, largely
in Europe in the late 1800s.
This was one in a
museum in Berlin.
And some of what
this shows is you
can make out some of
the different names
of the atolls in the Marshall
Islands all the way from Ebon
in the south, up to
Bikini in the north, which
is where Alson is from.
So some of these
stick charts map out
wave patterns in relation
to the islands, sometimes
current formations.
But those dark lines
that are labeled as okar,
those are representing wave
patterns that would actually
be kind of like a sailing path
between different island pairs.
And so some of
this does represent
large interaction spheres
between different island
groups.
However, historically,
the Marshallese
have faced some of the most
intense moments of colonialism
ever.
In about 100 years, they
went through regimes
by the Spanish, then the
Germans, then the Japanese,
and then the Americans.
So there were a lot
of social changes
that happened from this.
Missionization came in,
totally fundamentally altering
religious belief systems,
which impacted voyaging.
Under the German
colonial administration
prior to World War I,
they put bans on voyaging,
where it was illegal to
actually sail on canoes.
And then right
after World War II,
the US started a 12-year
program of nuclear testing
from 1946 to 1958, as part
of their nuclear weapons
testing era.
And as this relates to what
we're talking about today,
the site where a lot of
these tests took place
is the atoll of Bikini.
And this is one of the
images from that time period.
And I don't have an image
up here of a different test.
It was codenamed Bravo.
It was the world's first weapons
grade thermonuclear detonation.
And that took place
on March 1st, 1954.
The fallout from that landed
on a neighboring atoll named
Bikini--
- Rongelap.
- Sorry, of Rongelap, thank you.
And there was a
whole series of tests
that went into place, such
as biomedical experimentation
without consent.
And what this meant was
that the people of Rongelap
experienced a lot of
direct radiation exposure.
And they have been since this--
there's a very
complicated history here.
But they're, essentially, off of
their atoll living as refugees,
in the sense of nuclear exodus,
because they can't live there
anymore.
Related to our story
is on Rongelap,
this was a traditional
navigational school
that, possibly if that
testing hadn't happened,
there would have been probably
about 10 youth in the 1940s
and '50s that would
have kept learning here
in a traditional style of
how to navigate by the waves.
One of those young
people was a young boy
named Korent Joel, who later
became known as Captain Korent.
And because of this
testing, he never
had the chance to
really fully become
a navigator, although he had a
lot of navigational knowledge
that he had learned.
So fast forwarding, by the
time the 1990s rolls around,
he is getting a lot older.
There was finally
some appropriate ways
in the Marshalls
for him to start
to share some of his knowledge.
He was beginning to have the
permission from his chiefs
that were governing
him about how
to talk about the navigational
knowledge that he knew.
But, ultimately, he
was not a navigator.
He had not taken a test that
would have allowed him to be
sanctioned as a navigator.
And so he knew a
lot about the waves,
but not all of the system.
So he actually had this
call, kind of invitation,
for a team of essentially
anthropologists and scientists
to come in to both
help him fulfill
his breadth of knowledge to
understand some of the wave
dynamics, but also to validate
and verify some of the ideas
behind his wave theories.
And so, essentially, he
catapulted this program
as an invitation for
myself, initially,
to come in, to work
with Alson, which
he'll talk about right now.
And that, ultimately,
his dream was
to have a physicist
and an oceanographer
come and help him understand
the theories underlying
how these waves were forming
that he was trying to use.
And I'd just like to mention
this now that he passed away
in January of this year.
So it's a pretty sad
time for the Marshallese.
But his direct person
that he was teaching
is sitting right here.
So Alson Kelen, has
been his apprentice
that's been learning under him.
And I just wanted
to highlight as well
that what we're talking about,
it is very time sensitive.
So we were also working with
some elders from Rongelap.
These were people that
were slightly older
than the navigator
Captain Korent Joel.
This was his uncle, Isao
Eknilang, his aunt Lijohn
Eknilan, and another
relative, Willie Mewkto.
Lijohn and Willie have
since passed away.
Only Isao survives.
So there still is this pocket
of traditional knowledge.
But it's just barely
hanging in there.
And so what we're
trying to do today
is not only learn
about with these waves
from a physical
oceanographic perspective.
But we're also trying
to feed into Alson
to allow him the way--
to facilitate the ways that he
can perpetuate this knowledge.
And with that, I'm going
to pass on to Alson.
- I was really starting to enjoy
Joe's talk, then he finished.
Before I do my two
minutes presentation,
I'm going to do a little chant.
And this is a navigational chant
that I try to teach-- well,
I teach at the school,
and not just the chant,
but the definition of it,
and the meaning of it,
so the kids would feel
the cultural pride
and the self-esteem.
Anyway, [CHANTING].
Usually, you'd say
this three times
to get their spirit going.
Now, their spirit is gone.
So 25 years ago, I actually
lived in Oregon before.
And 25 years ago, I went
back to the Marshall's.
As Joe mentioned, I
originated from Bikini Atoll.
I actually lived
there for four years
before we got relocated
because this is the nuclear--
it was too radiated
for us to live there.
So we moved to Majuro.
And then I went to
high school in Hawaii.
So I lived in
Oregon for a while.
And 25 years ago, I went back.
And I worked for the National
Museum in the Marshall's.
I was very excited because,
one of the thing that when
I grew up in Bikini, one
of the things we had was we
had a sailing canoe.
And my father used
to take me out a lot.
And he would tell
me all these stories
about them voyaging between
Bikini, Rongelap, and Wotho.
So that's-- it was like
already embedded in me.
We didn't have TV.
So in the evening, my
father would open his arm.
And I would lay flat on
the arm, and close my eyes.
And that was my TV.
He would tell me the story.
And the word for Marshallese,
we say, [MARSHALLESE]..
That mean little men, use
your arms as your pillow,
because when you use their
arm as a pillow, you learn,
you talk, and you learn.
And it's funny, because
the canoe that we
use for our voyaging studies
is called [MARSHALLESE],,
which mean forehead
to forehead, you
share the knowledge, the skills.
So when you lay your arm,
you [INAUDIBLE] on the arm,
you actually exchange that.
So 25 years ago, I was involved
in a documentation project.
And our job was to go
from atoll to atolls
to document the step by
step construction of canoes.
And our last
project I went to, I
was working with a colleague
of mine from San Diego.
He was a surfer boy named
Dennis [? Alicio. ?]
All he knew was building
wooden boats, and go surfing.
So him and we, we kind
of connect pretty well,
because all I knew at
the time was fishing.
So we were in Ujae documenting
the canoeing culture.
Most of the time,
you go into town.
So that was kind of good for
me, because I could actually
directly learn my culture.
But while we were doing all that
work all over the Marshall's, I
actually, especially
me, see a lot
of young people coming to the
program, coming to the site.
And I was very happy,
because my thinking was, yes,
they are very into
learning their culture.
I learned later that these young
people actually, a lot of them
are dropouts.
A lot of them do not pass
the high school exam.
And in the outer island in
the Marshall's, if you do not
pass the high school
exam, at the age of 14,
that's pretty much it.
You get to start thinking about
making a living out of making
oil, or then starting a family.
So my colleague and I,
says, you know what?
When we get to Majuro, we're
going to start a school.
We have to start a
school of some sort.
So when we went back to Majuro,
and we finished of our project
with the National Museum,
both of us were jobless.
So we sat down and
said, well, what
do we know about
starting a school?
Pretty much zero.
What kind of skills do we have?
Nothing.
The only skill we
have was the skill
that we learn
traditionally, the skill
that was passed to
us from the masters.
But I like to note that in
the Marshall's, the skill is
actually passed on from
generation to generation
with family.
So you have to be adopted in
order to learn the skills.
And when we were on Ujae
studying this, documenting,
a lot of the master
builders, they
were doing all the
measurement behind their back,
even though it was
the permission--
so you have to go to the
chief to get the permission.
So even though you get the
permission from the chief,
they were still
hesitant, because it have
to be from a family to family.
So we decided that we're going
to use the documented knowledge
to train the young people.
But, unfortunately, we didn't
have the money to do it.
So I'm just going
to quickly give it--
just go a little bit
outside of my talk
and talk about this
little funny story.
So we had this voyaging
canoe we built on Ujae.
So when this project was done,
we sailed this canoe from Ujae
to Kwajalein, which is about
130 miles, and then from Ujae
to Kwajalein, which
is about 250 miles.
So I was the caretaker
of this canoe.
And I started to bring in the
young people, the young guys,
so we can go
sailing, and fishing.
And, of course, we
didn't have any money.
I was volunteering.
So one day, an Australian
ambassador came in.
And he asked me if I could
take him out sailing.
And I said, sure.
So I took him out sailing.
And he says, well,
I really enjoy this.
Can you tell me your
dream about this?
So I told him my dream.
I want to start a school
using the documented
knowledge to teach the
young people that--
the dropouts.
And I tell him this story.
And then when we
finish, he says, yeah,
write me a proposal.
Never done that
before in my life.
So he came back three days.
And he says, where' my
Proposal And I said, well,
I put the dates.
And I'm still
deciding, is it dear
who it may concern, or dear sir?
He said, you know what?
Here's $10,000.
You start the program.
And I will write the
proposal for you.
At that time, I had
a good friend, Dr.
Andrew [INAUDIBLE] who
was working for land grant
at the college in
the Marshall's.
We always talk about canoes.
And every time that
we talk about canoes,
he says, you bring me
$100, I will double it,
$200, I will double it.
I said, what do
you mean, double?
I'll give you $400.
I ran to his office.
I knock on the door.
I open it.
He says, what's going on?
I pull out the check.
He says, $10,000.
He says, OK, what am I
supposed to do with it?
I said, well, remember,
100, 200, 400?
He said, yeah, but you know,
but there's procedures.
You have to write me a proposal.
I said, what is
this about proposal?
The Australian wrote
a proposal for me.
How come the American can
not write a proposal for me?
And that money started
the canoe program.
We started call
around, and call,
Hawaii, big islands,
to get wood to start
up up our A-frame building
to start a canoe program,
because we were just
doing it on the beach.
So you can see there that we've
been bringing young people.
The first picture,
you saw the canoe.
We teach them the cultural part.
We use canoe as the medium.
We also, now we just
have this addition
to the project is the
carving part of it.
But we found out that
what we need also to do
is to have counselors
on life skills
if we want to really
work with the dropouts
to complete the
picture of training.
And not only the training
part is important,
but you need to
do something fun.
So they make learning fun.
And, actually the
cultural practice.
So we start canoe races.
So I went to all the mariners
from different atolls.
I said, bring the best
of the best, and we will,
too, the top the best
of the best in Majuro.
And, of course, nobody
want to lose a race.
So they brought all
the best of the best.
And we started
doing canoe races.
And the canoe knowledge,
to canoe tradition,
in the Marshall's has been
expanded tremendously.
A lot of the people, because
of the canoe races, because
of the schools,
people are building
canoes in the outer islands.
And, of course, fuel
is so expensive.
For communities
that make $1 a day,
the fuel costs is
$9 to $10 a gallon.
It's unreasonable.
So since then, we'll see
transport, canoeing culture,
it's there.
So it's not just the canoeing
that we're kind of teaching.
But now that we're getting
involved more and more
with the team, I'm the only
person here that have no PhD.
They don't call me doctor.
So I'm so happy to have the
group with me so they can--
I just talk.
And they do all the numbers
and all that stuff for me.
So this is one of
our stick chart.
And this stick chart here is--
Joe mentioned the name Isao.
He was actually
supposed to be here.
But he was not
feeling very good.
So, anyhow, this is his stick
chart to explain the swells.
And, of course, this
is Joe's explanation
of this stick chart.
And you can see
this [MARSHALLESE]..
the swells that
come from the north.
And [MARSHALLESE] is this stick,
the swell that comes from east.
And [MARSHALLESE],,
it comes from south.
And [MARSHALLESE] is the
swells that comes from west.
And Marshallese
believe that these
swells you use to show the
direction where you are going.
And, of course, here
is the [MARSHALLESE]..
And [INAUDIBLE] is part of
the mixture of these two.
And [MARSHALLESE],, this
one is [MARSHALLESE]..
The word [MARSHALLESE]
is pouring outside.
So I think more detail
will come as we--
the other presentations.
So thank you very much.
- Well, it's a
pleasure to be here.
And there's also a story
behind my presence here.
I'm from Holland.
And in the Netherlands, we
need to protect our country
against the anger of the sea.
So we are used to know the wave
environment on the North Sea.
And we built our water
defenses for that.
So my professional
career is always
in the development and
application of wave models
to predict for safety reasons.
But four years
ago, I was reading
a book about navigation.
And there was one book
chapter about wave navigation.
And then I thought,
that's interesting.
I didn't know that application.
So during my research, I
came into contact with Joe.
And then we had a lot
of email correspondence.
And then three years ago,
Joe asked me in January,
I'm going to Marshall
Islands on an expedition,
do you want to join?
What do you say, no?
Of course, yes.
So that's how I became
involved in this project.
And the very interesting part
is that wave navigation is there
for ages, many
hundreds of years.
And in the last
few hundred years,
there were people trying to
document it, and describe it.
And that was also my interest.
So, as was introduced by
John, the last navigators
there wanted the scientists
becoming involved.
So my research
started by looking
at the waves in
the whole Pacific,
and how they affect the
Marshallese Islands.
So what you can see here is the
whole Pacific animation of--
well, this is the winds.
And the whole Pacific is
often called the quiet ocean.
That only relates to
the equatorial region.
But in the south, you
can see the [INAUDIBLE],,
all the big winds near
Antarctica, and in the north
also near Alaska.
Those winds are generating
all kinds of waves.
And these waves, they radiate
over the whole of the Pacific,
and then enter the
Marshall Islands.
So we can here see a snapshot
of the waves that are still
actively driven by the wind.
And the next is--
those are the ways that
escape the wind fields.
And they are called
the swell waves.
And the swell
waves, we know, are
waves that are moving
gently over the ocean.
And these swell waves can
propagate tens of thousands
of kilometers from the very
south to the very north.
And halfway, they pass the
area of the Marshall Islands.
So the Marshall Islands
are affected by local waves
generated by the
trade winds, and also
by the waves coming from
Antarctica, from the south
and from the north.
And as Alson told, waves move
in all kind of directions.
And because of that,
the Marshall Islands
have the unique
feature that there
are all kinds of interesting and
stable wave systems passing by.
And because they last
for a number of days,
you can rely on them
for navigation purposes.
So this is an animation of the
southern part of the ocean.
This is one feature.
This is a period of the
waves, of all the swell
fields, crossing each other.
And as you can imagine,
just sit down on one point,
and you will see a different
wave systems coming
from the south, from the west,
and the north at the same time.
And this is, really,
the information
that was picked up
by the navigators
to help in the steering
over the ocean.
So the next step is we can look
in more detail at what happens
over the course of a year.
So this is a plot-- let's just
concentrate on the upper part.
On the horizontal axis, you see
each day in a particular year.
On the vertical axis,
you see the direction
from which a certain
wave field is coming.
And what you can see, you
can see bands of waves.
In the north, there's 360.
You see all the dots.
They represent the swell
coming from the north.
And it's almost always present.
There's also a southerly swell
almost present all of the year.
And at 90 degrees,
that is the trade winds
waves generated from the east.
And they are also
persistently existing.
So this persistence
makes it feasible
that the people there
can navigate reliably
between all the oceans.
If you then go one
level deeper, the waves
come from the islands.
And they interact
with the islands.
So what you can see there
is a schematic diagram
of the green island.
The waves come from the east.
They bounce against the islands.
They have reflections.
And people can pick
up the reflected wave
from the islands.
On the other hand,
behind the island,
the waves bends around it.
And they create cross patterns.
And now, the
remarkable feature is
that the navigators can
look at the sea surface,
feel it, and then
know where they are,
with respect to the island.
So that was all schematic.
And now, we wanted to bring
in the science in more detail.
So we applied some
computer modeling.
And we just looked in detail
what happens with all the swell
waves, and how they interact
with the wave with the island.
So you can see some shallow
water effects around islands.
The waves bend
around the islands.
And at some point,
you can see a bit
of a reflection in the island.
So this is a very nice tool.
And we just started
playing with this tool
to unravel all the intricacies
of what all the people know
there for ages.
But now, we want to
bring it in more detail,
and help them understanding why
all the wave phenomena happen.
So this is just another example.
And here, you can
see a bigger island.
And the reflection of the
waves is more easily visible.
Well, two years ago,
we were in the ocean.
And we did a traveling from
the island-- the red line is
the course of the canoe.
The eastern course is going up.
We went to the islands of Aur.
And a few days later,
we went down again.
And we used, again,
the computer modeling
to reconstruct what are
the wave conditions.
And John took all
kind of measurements
of the waves and the winds.
And we put them together.
And, luckily, they agreed a bit.
But this is the
level that we also
can see the shadowing
effect of the islands.
So if a navigator go from
one island to another island,
it can see all kinds of
features and differences
in the ocean environment.
And that is, really, the trick--
reading the environment, and
reading the wave parents,
and then know where
you are, almost.
So the next step
is now we want to--
the navigator is
standing on the canoe.
And he feels like
the wave motion.
So what we are trying
to do is we just
t make a reconstruction
of the wave surface.
The red dot represents a
canoe going through the sea.
And the lower two panels show
the vertical movement, the eve,
how the canoe goes up and down.
And the lower panel,
the black line,
is the pitch as the canoe
goes this direction.
And the red line is the
roll this direction.
So this is the first
step in our analysis.
What do the navigators feel?
So the next
challenge is, really,
to put instruments on the canoe,
and then really measure what
are the motions of the canoe?
And that will help
us understanding
the whole way of wave piloting.
So from the big ocean
skill, to the scale
with the islands, and the
scale of the sea, of the ship.
So this is really a challenge.
And we have a lot of work to do.
Thank you
Thanks.
So what is my toolkit?
I don't know.
My toolkit is that
of a physicist.
So it's not clear.
So I'll pick up where
Gerbrant left off.
And the indigenous
navigators will tell you
that it is the sense of
the motion that they have.
Sometimes, they'll lie on
their back on the canoe,
close their eyes, and feel it.
We were talking with Alson
today about it, and about how
he felt the waves.
And he said he actually felt
more comfortable navigating
at night than he
does during the day,
because he said his
eyes play tricks on him.
And so there is this notion,
you don't look at the waves.
You actually feel them.
And to some extent,
what I did was not
only to try to help
document the voyage.
But I also try to put
my feet in the shoes
of an apprentice navigator,
sort of knowing what I learned,
and how well can I do from
what I've been taught?
And so it's like baby's
first steps in wave piloting,
is the best way I could put it.
So it was a lot to
juggle at that point.
I think [INAUDIBLE],,
who we talked to,
said that you feel
it in your stomach.
And, in fact, there's this one
mysterious notion that we're
still trying to unravel.
And I'll share with you
what I think it might be.
There are these paths to
connect pairs of atolls
in the Marshall Islands
called a [MARSHALLESE]..
And it's been described as
a disturbed path of water
that connects pairs of atolls.
And it's not a reflection
or a refraction,
as Gerbrant described.
That's something different.
There are words for that too.
But this [MARSHALLESE]
is this mysterious path
of disturbed water that
connects pairs of attols.
And I've been scratching my
head as to what, exactly, this
represents, because the
descriptions I was given
didn't really seem
physically correct to me.
But this is a bit where
kind of the art of trying
to understand the culture
and the physical descriptions
is difficult.
And one of the
things that is true,
at least for me
and other examples,
are, if I were to
ask you, how do you
know to get from here to there?
You would just say,
well, I know it.
I mean, there is
this intuitive kind
of sense of how you get
from one place to the other
that you develop.
And it's sometimes difficult
to then turn around
to somebody who hasn't done it
and then explain it to them.
So we're dealing with
maybe the difficulty
of communicating something
that's intuitive knowledge.
Or maybe it's the language that
is being used to describe it.
So the idea is, can we feel it?
And so that was, at least, one
of the things that I was hoping
to come away from
this voyage with,
in addition to documenting it.
So here's another view of
part of the Marshall Islands.
The capital is Majuro.
We all flew in
there, except Alson
was there, and
spent a fair amount
of time getting used to things.
And then we departed
Majuro with Alson
and his crew on the Jitdam
Kapeel, which is the outrigger,
sailed north to Aur, and
I'll described the voyage,
visited the island of
Tobal in the atoll of Aur,
and then had a
return voyage back.
And so my job was to
try to document it.
But I also wanted
to understand how
their systems might operate.
So here is a little
video clip of the Jitdam
Kapeel in the [INAUDIBLE] Aur.
And you can see the
outrigger, which
is bouncing up and down a bit.
It's designed to do that.
It has to flex.
And that's one of the amazing
aspects of the engineering
of these Marshallese canoes, is
that you cannot rigidly attach
this outrigger.
It has to be designed to have
a kind of give and take to it.
And so it's remarkable, if
you see these things up front.
The other thing is
that the outrigger
balances against the wind.
So the canoe might just
heal over at an angle.
And so what the outrigger does
is it counterbalances that.
And it also helps keep
it tracked straight.
So I don't know how
many of you are sailors.
But if you've ever
heard the term leeway,
but under the
influence of the wind
you can actually
get pushed sideways.
And so the design of these
things are remarkable.
They almost have no
leeway whatsoever.
So they track very
straight, and go
exactly where you want to go.
OK, so the outgoing
voyage, which I think you
can see here--
so I hope you can see that.
Here's the track of the
outgoing voyage here.
Can you all see that?
So I had a GPS with me.
So part of it was just to
figure out, where are we,
each of the places we go.
We left this cut
close to sunset.
This is the way I tried
to indicate visually
on the map the swells.
So the swell
direction, the motion
of the winds, and the
waves, and the swells,
were in the direction
of the arrow.
And the crests were
perpendicular to that.
So it just helps
visualization, my way
of visualizing the waves.
So there is this set of waves.
When we first left
the cut of Majuro,
the waves were coming directly
at us, so from the north.
But as we left
Majuro, towards sunset
the waves were then
coming at an angle,
and eventually from the west.
And in the middle
of the night, I
swear I felt some motion
of a swell from the north.
What Alson did, and
he'll tell you later,
was he was concerned that we
were going to actually run
right into the reef of Aur
in the middle of the night,
because a very strong wind
kicked up as we were sailing.
And so he made the
decision to sail somewhat
to the east of Aur.
And then he estimated that
the sunrise would happen
when we were to the east.
And then we would sail into Aur.
It was a very rough night.
And we got splashed
in the chase boat.
I think all of us--
like, at least, I got incredibly
seasick on the way out.
And it was a really bumpy ride.
And when we got out there,
there was a maneuver
to turn towards Aur
that Alson wanted to do.
But it proved to be difficult,
especially because the rope
holding the mast broke.
So we used the chase
vessel to tow us in.
So that was interesting.
We then arrived in Tobal,
which is in the north of Aur.
So you see here, some of
the crew taking supplies in.
So we took supplies here.
You see Alson with, I guess
effectively the mayor of Aur.
Is that who that is?
Yeah.
So here, you see some
of the supplies there.
And we had an amazing feast.
I mean, I've never been
greeted by a group of strangers
so kindly.
It was just unbelievable.
And we spent a few days,
and had a return journey.
So I didn't know
exactly what to expect,
and how to document this thing.
So we were exposed to the ocean.
So this is my toolkit.
And I had a GPS with me.
I had a handheld
weather station,
which had an ananometer
to measure wind speed.
And I had a compass
to get the heading.
And so using these three
things and documenting it,
I could figure out where
the wind was blowing.
I could use my
body to figure out
where the waves were
going, just by feeling
the motion of the canoe.
I was able to figure out
what the current was doing,
because I could calculate
from the heading,
and the way the sails were
pointed in the canoe, where
they should be going.
But then when they were going in
a slightly different direction,
I attributed that to current.
So just using some native
smarts, and an Excel
spreadsheet, and the stuff
that I pulled together,
I was able to reproduce
a lot of the course,
especially on the
way back, because it
was a little bit calmer.
So here, you see my notebook.
It looks like a
bunch of scribbles.
But I was able to
reconstruct the voyage.
So here is the return trip,
at least an indication
of the return trip.
So we went through
the cut in Aur
I guess a few hours
before sunset.
And it was interesting.
I was curious about what this
path one could follow from one
atoll to another would be.
And what I found was that
the trade wind swell always
seemed to be coming
perpendicular to our path,
moving perpendicular
to our path.
And our path was actually
an arc of some kind.
And so that was a
clue that, perhaps,
if you follow this arc, that you
would find your way to Majuro.
Also in the middle of
the night, what I did
was I lay on the
back on the canoe,
and just try to feel the motion.
So it went side to side rolling
three times, one, two, three.
And then I had one up and down.
So I figured there
was a trade wind--
and this happened
over and over again.
So there was a trade
wind swell that
was rolling me back and forth.
And then there were some
swell from the north that
was pitching me up and down.
And I wrote this
into my notebook,
because I was kind
of like, this is it.
I'm staking myself
to this observation.
And it better work out.
OK, just to show you that
the observations, at least
of the this path that I thought
we were following, was correct,
here is the hind
cast that Gerbrant
got by just looking at the
winds from the North Pacific,
and the trade winds, and so on.
And, indeed, I basically
nailed the correct observations
of where the trade wind
waves and swells were going.
So I kind of got that right
from the observations.
One of the things that
was a little scary
was that it looked like we
were getting blown off course
to the west, which Alson
was also concerned about,
indicating there was
some sort of current.
Alson felt a current
of some kind.
This is just an intermediate
plot that I used.
This is showing, instead of
the direction of the swells,
this is showing the wind speed
that I got from the ananometer,
and figuring out the
true wind direction.
So you could see, we
had wind speeds kind
of approaching 10 knots.
But they died down
around sunrise,
but then the picked up again.
And using that,
knowing which way--
this is just a diagram which I'm
not going to walk you through.
But this dotted line indicates
the performance characteristics
of a proto Hokulea vessel,
which is the one the Polynesian
Voyaging Society uses, and
just did an around the world
trip with.
Here's the Jitdam Kapeel,
which is much more performant.
So it's like a Ferrari compared
to a minivan or something,
I guess for lack
of a better term.
So using that and the
information I had,
I was able to figure
out the currents.
And the currents were quite
strong near Aur and Majuro.
And this was what was
sweeping us to the west.
And this is also what Alson
was highly concerned about.
In any case, he'll talk maybe
a little bit more about this,
we also had the wave
data from this period.
And this is a weird plot.
But let me just
sketch out what it is.
So the angle around this
dot is the direction
that the swells are moving,
and the waves are moving.
So this bit here are
the trade wind waves
that are coming from
the east and they're
moving toward the west.
So you see this big blob here.
And then the radial
axis has frequency.
So the longer the
period, the closer
you will be to the center.
So a very long period swell
would be close to the center.
So if I just let
this evolve here--
and this was actually--
it was, basically, two
years to the day to today
when we did this.
And so when I got this
plot, it looked at it.
I said, OK, well there's
the trade wind swell.
And look at that.
There's a swell from the north.
And it's there.
And I was like, yeah.
So I was able to get the
swell, get the directions,
and also feel this north
swell my first time out.
And I was just overjoyed
when I saw this.
So maybe I'm over-playing
it for you folks.
But that was my baby's
first book of wave piloting.
So I'm just going
to turn it over
to Alson for his
impressions of the trip out.
So you can just
talk about it now.
Riff on it.
- Yeah, I've been
very fortunate to give
a talk about these kind
of stuff after they
explain all the details.
So the trip out was
very interesting.
First of all, we forgot to cook
our meal, to cook our rice.
Of course, in the Pacific,
rice is a pretty big thing.
So we used a teapot.
And said, OK, we're
going to cook the rice,
take all the rice out,
and cook the hot water.
So that was a pretty good
way to start off the sail.
And when we went out,
it was still daytime.
So I was kind of
looking at the swells,
hoping to find the
strong eastern swell that
would show me where to go.
And as we go further
out from Majuro,
then you could kind
of feel that then.
Of course, like John
was saying, because I
keep repeating that I am always
afraid to sail during the day,
because there is so many
type of waves and currents.
And as a student,
I'd rather eliminate
a lot of the those thing,
and just feel my way out.
So as we go out, there was a
lot of swells, rains, wind.
And every time there
was a swell coming,
we would face the canoe
right into the wind.
And at that time, we
were going backwards.
And having all
that taking place,
we trying to estimate where
we would be if we don't--
I mean, I try to estimate
where we would be.
So keep in mind that
from previous voyages,
I kind of know what
time I would Aur.
It would be kind of dangerous
to go directly there.
So we were going as far east
as possible to get there.
And then the plan was to--
because the wind
comes like this--
was go to out that
direction, and then just
kind of have a nice,
easy sail down.
But, unfortunately,
when we look up
at the mast, the rope
that holds the sail up,
was halfway almost.
It was pretty dangerous.
So we brought it down.
And we got towed in.
On the way back, it
was a very nice sail.
As soon as we got
out, we could see
that there was a current
pushing toward east.
But the problem is, the
wind kind of died out.
So we were pushed out
more than we wanted.
So when the wind start to
pick up in the morning,
we try to come as
close east as possible,
because these two islands,
I know that the farther you
come east--
I think the more advantages
if I were to come east.
But the currents
were pushing as west.
So there's another
island toward the south.
So I keep saying,
oh, I hope we don't
go to Jaluit, which is far.
But, fortunately, the wind pick
up during the morning hours.
And we were able to
come in into directly
into the pass, which was a
good feeling, because instead
of going anywhere
else, we actually
coming toward the pass.
So it was a pretty good feeling.
It was a success, I think.
So where do we go from here?
We visit schools, and
talk about canoe programs,
and talk about our culture.
And from what we've learned
from this trip, personally,
I want to continue.
I want to make sure that
what we have gathered so far
would be something to look
at, and to move forward,
and trying to figure
out ways to make sure
that we complete our work.
Joe mentioned that he came
in and start talking--
I mean, Ben Finney and Joe
talking to Captain Korent.
And one of the goals
that Captain Korent has,
because he was a navigator,
he wants to have one side
is tradition navigation, and
the scientific, because even me,
when people ask me
about certain swells,
I can talk about the swells.
But the details of it, and
scientific detail of it,
I don't know.
So I think it would make this
study even 100% better if we
put those two fields together.
A canoe there it's
actually in Hawaii.
It's called Okeanos
Marshall Islands.
It was donated to
the Marshall Islands
as part of this
sustainable sea transport.
Of course, you probably
know that Marshall Islands
is a low lying islands, is most
affected by climate change.
So one of the big things that
our government is going out
and talk about climate change.
And this is one way--
of course, you know,
again, Joe explain about
these islands and 750,000
square miles.
So we're so small and big at
the same time, which means
that our islands are so small.
But, yes, we use probably
more fuel than any other--
some other countries--
around the world.
And for a country that
talk about climate change,
I think we need to change our
attitude toward transportation,
and any other means
of fossil usage.
So we got this canoe.
And I think that's the
plan now, is to try
to see if we can utilize it.
And, of course,
this canoe is going
to be under the auspices of
the University of the South
Pacific.
So it's even better, because
it's an educational institute.
So I think that's the goal
now, is to rethink and re-plan
the future of this
program, and of course
to utilize our canoe
program, and the youth
that I'm working with.
So let's see.
What else?
- We're good.
- That's good?
OK.
- So I guess what we'll probably
do is just take some questions
and have some discussion.
So there's a microphone.
And I'll let-- I guess
somebody else can adjudicate
the questions, or something.
And we'll try to take them.
And if you're going
to address us,
you might want to tell
us who you're asking.
Yeah, OK.
- Hi, thank you very
much, very interesting.
I guess I would address it
to you as the physicist.
What determines the
periodicity of swells?
Is it the dynamic
strength of the wind?
Is it the distance it travels?
And would they be then
differentiable, north, south,
west?
- That's a wonderful question.
So what determines the height
and the period of the swells
is what's called fetch,
which is the duration
and the time over which
the wind has been blowing.
So the longer the
fetch, typically,
the longer the period,
especially the stronger the
wind, the longer the period.
So if there's a hurricane
out in the Atlantic,
you can get swells that have
periods of maybe 22 seconds
or something like that.
And they travel at
50, 60 miles an hour.
So the sign of a
hurricane with the swells
can well outrun the
hurricane itself.
And it's thought that
maybe Columbus was
able to determine that
there was a hurricane
in his fourth voyage by
looking at these swells.
So they do have a
different character.
The swells from the southern
ocean have very long periods
associated with them.
I mean, Gerbrant could say more.
But I'm sort of thinking
14 to 22 seconds.
The North Pacific swells can
also be somewhat as long.
But sometimes in
my gut, I feel them
a little bit shorter period
than the Southern Ocean swells.
And the trade wind swells
tend to be more wind
driven and steeper face.
So you tend to get
swells that have periods
of like seven to 11 seconds.
So each one has kind of a
fingerprint associated with it.
That's kind of the short answer.
Would you agree?
- Yeah, I agree, yeah.
- So John, you
mentioned the Hokulea,
which has been very much in the
news recently because it just
re-entered Honolulu Harbor after
a three year circumnavigation.
So those last few days--
that's a double hollowed
outrigger canoe.
Is that right?
- It's a double-hulled
canoe, yes.
- Double-hulled-- so
the last few days,
I've been wondering about
among these different atolls,
these different Pacific
atolls, traditionally,
what is the overlap
in, for example,
boatbuilding technique,
in navigational technique,
and in maybe the theory behind
the navigational technique?
And what are the differences
between the Marshall Islands
and the Hawaiian
Islands, et cetera?
- Should I take a whack at it?
- Sure.
- OK.
Yeah, well, so as Joe said, the
navigation and canoe building
pretty much disappeared
in the Hawaiian Islands,
with the exception of these
small outriggers that were used
more for races than anything.
So the idea of the
double-hulled canoe
was developed by at least
a combination of, I guess,
Ben Finney, Joe's thesis
advisor, and an artist named
Herb [INAUDIBLE] who drew
a lot of paintings of what
he imagined the Hawaiians when
they were doing long distance
voyaging used.
And the large catamaran double
hull makes a lot of sense
for really long distance
voyage, like the 2,000 mile run
from Tahiti to Hawaii, because
for the smaller canoes,
like the Jitdam Kapeel,
with the smaller outrigger,
they really get a work out.
And the lashings get a
really heavy workout.
So the Hokulea was designed
to withstand a lot of beating,
like over a month
of ocean swells.
But there's not a lot
of extent information
about that structure,
although I guess
there was a recent
archaeological
find in the South Pacific of
a very large steering board.
So that sort of
backs that idea up.
The navigation
scheme, again, was
lost in the Hawaiian Islands.
So the way that Polynesian
voyaging society
approached this was that
they actually went to Satewa,
which is a Micronesian outlier.
And Alson will be
very quick to say
that this navigator,
[INAUDIBLE],,
learned from the
Marshallese at Bikini.
I don't know.
But he was a master navigator.
And he wanted to
propagate this, and was
visited by a number of writers.
So the Polynesian
Voyaging Society
invited [INAUDIBLE] to be the
first navigator on a Hokulea
run from Hawaii to Tahiti.
And very rapidly,
a Hawaiian named
[INAUDIBLE] Thompson came under
the tutelage of [INAUDIBLE]..
And [INAUDIBLE] system is
kind of idiosyncratic, not
so easy to learn.
So [INAUDIBLE] teamed
up with an astronomer
at the University of
Hawaii, Will Kyselka,
and spent a lot of time
in the planetarium there.
And I know he kind of
developed his own schema.
And I like to say it's
a bit of a mixture
of a Western navigation
scheme, but non-instrumented.
And I know it was
quite successful.
And so what he's been
doing is teaching this
to other members of the
Polynesian Voyaging Society.
So the difference is that
it's kind of a hybrid Western,
you know slash what they
learned from [INAUDIBLE] system.
Whereas in the Marshall
Islands, at least
we have this kind of unbroken
continuity, which also includes
stars.
For example, the names of
stars are actually directions
for sailing, in some cases.
So it's a substantial
difference,
if you're comparing
one to the other.
- Maybe I'd just
add a little bit
to the first part of your
question is that there seems
to be really wide consensus that
the navigation traditions that
kind of span the breadth
of the Pacific all share
some really common features.
So regardless of what atoll or
island community you're from,
there would be
fairly common ways
that you would, for
example, set an orientation
to start sailing, and how
you might take a back siding
to keep your course
going once you
start to get outside of land.
Dead reckoning procedures are
a little bit more complicated.
But once you kind of
hone in on an island,
there seems to be some
fairly common things,
whether it's looking
at birds that
are going to be nesting
at land at the night,
or certain cloud formations,
the wave pattern.
So there's kind
of a commonality.
But it seems that,
historically and over time,
certain island groups,
voyaging communities,
developed particular
techniques that were fairly--
became more elaborated
and developed
in those particular places.
So whereas if you asked almost
any Pacific navigator today,
even in the historical past,
they would all say, yes,
we know about wave reflections.
We use those all the time.
I think the difference is
that in the Marshall Islands,
it became very much
elaborated so that
was kind of the center
of the entire system.
I think that's the difference.
- Thanks.
Any of you know how to navigate
our health insurance system?
You don't have to answer.
You're from a different country.
I am very interested in
this question of the two
different kinds of knowledge.
One, I would characterize
as more experiential
and intuitive, and the other
more abstract and analytical.
And I don't know that we
need to say one is science
and the other isn't.
It may be different
kinds of knowledge.
And I like what you said, Mr.
Kelen, about these parallel,
keeping them both
going, not trying
to make one, if
I understood you,
not necessarily wanting
to make one the other,
but have them maybe parallel.
So I'd be interested
in any of you
might like to talk a little
bit about the ways in which
these forms of
knowledge are different,
and what meaning, if any,
you give to any of that?
- You want the question again?
You want to rephrase it for you?
OK, let me see if I can
rephrase it, and you can nod.
So we actually discussed this
this afternoon, to some extent.
So I'll try to reframe our
discussion this afternoon.
It was that, how did you
know there was a current?
And you said, well,
I can feel it.
And how did you know this?
And one of the things that
Alson said was that in his mind,
he was able to calculate, I
have to worry about the current.
I have to worry about the wind.
I know the wind's strong.
I think I'm going to be here.
There was a moment where
he was about 15 miles
off the southeast corner of Aur.
And Joe radioed
him, because that's
how we stayed in contact.
And he said, Alson, where
do you think you are?
He said, I think I'm like 10,
15 miles off the southeast
corner of Aur.
This was 2:30 in the morning.
And from the GPS, that
was exactly where he was.
And so I asked Alson,
do you use numbers,
moving at so many knots,
and it's been so many hours?
No, it was just as his feeling.
And then we had this discussion
about, how do we teach this?
Do we bring in science to it?
And Do we teach the
Marshallese the science?
And Joe said, no, you want to
be really careful, because you
don't want to infect people
with these Western notions.
And so we really went
back and forth with it.
And I don't know if you want
to say anything on this point.
Or I did have a
thought about it, but.
- Again, I will say
that, mostly, the feeling
and the image that
was in my mind,
I picture where I was going.
And it's so funny, because
the question you were asking
is the same question that we
could ask a master navigator
in the Marshall Islands.
They would say the same thing.
We were feeling our way with
the currents coming, the swells.
And we always joke
around, and say that's
why a lot of Marshallese
have big stomach, because we
navigate with our stomach.
- Is it kind of terrain?
Among other things, is
it a kind of terrain?
- Yes.
- So a lot of times in
this realm of navigation,
we'll talk about certain
marks, or certain signs that
would indicate the direction
and distance toward land.
And most of those in
the Marshall Islands
are described as sea marks.
So it's the idea a particular
wave 20 miles off land,
or a surging current
15 miles this way,
could be a mark to indicate
the direction and distance.
So, yeah, you're exactly right.
It's kind of like
this spatial field
of this multitude
of waves coming
from every possible direction.
And somehow, the
navigator has to filter
all that out, figure out
what are the strong signals
to figure out that
land is that way.
Yeah, so it is very much an
embodied kind of experience
that, at a practical
level, navigators
are probably drawing from.
- I can add to that, that,
although we use computer
models, I realize that our
knowledge is still incomplete,
because all the stories about
feeling the reflected waves,
just what was told before,
we try to reconstruct it
with our models.
But we are still not there.
All the computer models
are simplifications.
And I expect that we
can still learn a lot
from what the navigators know.
So that is one of the
challenges of really unraveling
what do they feel.
- And just to kind of
tie this-- and, sorry,
this wasn't the question.
But to tie this into
the bigger thing
that we're doing, to what
I said in the beginning
was just mentioning that
Captain Korent, Joel,
who kind of started
this project,
his whole goal was to try to get
the scientific understanding.
And part of it was to validate
the knowledge that he already
knew, to kind of increase
the prestige of him
and his knowledge.
But the other part was
to flesh out the ideas.
And so one quick
example is there's
an image up here of a wave
pattern called [MARSHALLESE]..
And it's this kind
of refracted wave
pattern on the leeward
side of an atoll.
And when you think conceptually
about what that is,
it's almost identical to what
the navigators talk about.
I mean, it's almost match for
match, OK, we've got refracted
swells coming in.
But then we have other things,
like the [MARSHALLESE] like
John was talking about,
that from a first glance
make no sense,
oceanographically.
And that's what we're
trying to figure out.
So it's kind of this duality
of both validating and trying
to add some explanations.
- And I just want to
add one more thing.
So I teach a course here
and one of the things
that I want the
students to do is
to be able to find directions
from the stars in the sky.
And so what's interesting
is like a technique
that I've taught
myself, but you have
to memorize the coordinates
of the stars, the declination,
and what is effectively
the longitude of the star,
if you like.
And so they find it tedious.
And it's like, why we
have to take this quiz?
And they have to write
down the numbers.
And they have graph paper.
And they have to plot the
stars, and all this other stuff.
But then they have a quiz on
the roof of the Science Center.
And it's really something of an
epiphany, because what happens
is all those numbers
and stuff just fall out.
And you're looking at the stars.
And you say, that's Regulus.
That's Altar.
That's Vega.
And all of the sudden, all
those numbers and all that stuff
falls away.
And it's intuitive.
It's like if I showed you
a map of North America,
and I tilted it sideways,
and I said, which way is up?
You say, oh, that way is up.
And I say, how do you know?
Because I've seen
it a million times.
It's the same way that once you
learn the stars, you look up.
And oh yeah, I know
what the directions are,
and that sort of thing.
So you can take this kind
of scientific approach
to learning something.
And then it develops
into intuition.
And I think it's just one
path that you can take.
It's not necessarily exclusive.
But I think it
could also speed up
having to go out on the water
over and over, and over again.
It could seed
learning, in some way.
- Continuing the stars a
bit, is there any evidence
that they used the
sun or the stars
to add to their wave knowledge?
- Well, I think as a supplement,
I mean, do you want to talk?
- Yeah, the stars, we use
the stars, but not as much.
Mostly, we use the swells.
- Captain Korent,
he told us one time
that the stars are not as
reliable as the swells,
because the stars are
always moving around.
That's a Marshallese conception.
- But here's one thing, though.
At sunset, Alson
did use the sunset
as a way of establishing the
directionality of the swells,
and assumed that
the swells were then
coming from the same direction
throughout the night.
- You used it as a calibration
thing from time to time.
- Yeah.
- I was curious about how
the boat design was affected
or interacted with the
actual idea of navigation,
and the type of navigation.
And just also as a sort of
aside, the traditional boats,
where did they get the materials
to build those large boats?
I mean, my
understanding of atolls
is they don't have
a lot of timber.
- Yeah, well, the boat
that we used, actually,
was built with
fiberglass, because it's
a learning vessel for the
young people, for the youth.
And it was funded by grants.
So it was part of the deal.
But in the olden days,
we built our boats
with breadfruit trees.
And Marshallese boats are
actually planks sewn together.
And every once in a while,
a drift log would come in.
But in the olden days,
drift log is like gold.
So if you find a drift log,
it belongs to the chief,
because that would be the next
voyaging canoe for the chief.
So, yes, and like I said, the
canoes were sewn together.
So on a voyage,
there is a baler.
And if the baler would
reach land a few times,
then they gave him a
piece of land as an oar,
because the canoes in those
days, if the water come
to your belly button, they say,
wow, that's a really dry canoe.
- Thanks for a
great presentation.
And I'm curious,
have you considered
adding a psychologist
or cognitive
psychologist to your team?
I was struck by that thought,
thinking about what you were
saying about feeling things.
And people have a sense of
time that psychologists still
don't understand.
It can be dark.
And some people are
very good at knowing
what time is is with no cues,
and other people are not.
And I don't think that
that's very well understood.
But I'm guessing that this
kind of navigating by feeling
is related to that.
So have you guys
thought about that?
- I've certainly consulted
with a large number
of cognitive psychologists.
- Do they have ideas?
- Yeah, I mean, it
certainly would help.
I mean, I read a lot of it
because it helps inform us.
So I'm thinking the same thing.
I haven't found anybody
that's really ready
to jump in with both feet.
So if you know somebody,
send them our way.
- I talk about psychologists, I
was part of a crew that sailed
[INAUDIBLE] from
Hawaii to Micronesia.
That was [INAUDIBLE]
last voyage.
But I was telling these guys
that every 5 to 30 minutes,
somebody had to
wash some dishes.
So we keep washing and
washing the dishes,
I think, just to get our
mind from the open ocean
that you see out there.
So that's-- so when you
talk about psychology,
that was first thing
that came to my mind.
- To pick up on that--
in the martial arts tradition,
the center of balance
is about three inches,
or three thumb lengths,
below your bellybutton.
It's called the [INAUDIBLE].
And in martial arts,
you move from there.
That your center of gravity.
That's also the second chakra
in the Indian yoga system.
So I'm wondering whether
your stomach, the feelings
in your stomach, relate to that
kind of idea of the [INAUDIBLE]
and the chakra.
- First I've heard of it.
But it's good to know.
- I would just--
I don't know if we know the
answer to that one right now.
But what John and
I kind of picked up
on going through some of
the academic literature
recently was this notion
of proprioception,
which is what
we've come to learn
is like it's a little
like kinesthetic motion.
And kinesthetic intelligence is
like when your body is actually
moving through something.
And vestibular would
be like if your body
is kind of swaying on a canoe.
But nobody's really
running on a canoe.
So it's really like--
proprioception is kind of
like these small, tiny, tiny
movements that somehow impact
your sense of where you are.
And so for the most
part, like if Alson
is sitting on the canoe,
he's just sitting.
Sorry, but he's
just sitting there
on the leeward
platform of a canoe
just rocking back and forth
with the motion of the canoe.
And so probably, it's
the tiny little feelings
of his leg pushing up
against the creaking wood.
And that's giving him a sense of
what's happening on the ocean.
And probably, this
term proprioception
is as close as we
can come to kind
of really getting
out what is probably
happening inside the body.
But it's a great question.
- What was that, second chakra?
I'll look that up.
- I had a question for Alson.
That journey that you
made between the islands,
have you done that many times?
- That was my second time.
- OK.
- So you had a
sense when you were
moving of the angle of
the waves to the boat.
And you knew when the angle of
the waves was going to change,
just the way a hill
might bend if someone
was walking along the
top of a mountain range
or something like that.
And you had a sense of the time
that the boat was traveling,
and when that angle
was supposed to happen.
And you knew exactly where you
were relative to an island.
Is that-- is it just like
you have a map in your brain?
And you just--
- I wish.
Something like that,
no just kidding.
Yeah, I think from the
first voyage I went on,
I knew the length,
I mean the time
it would take us to
sail from Majuro to--
- You knew the boat.
You knew the wind.
You knew the waves.
You knew the current.
- And when I was
going out, I think
my big concern was make
sure I don't hit the island.
And with all the winds
and the swells come in,
I want to go as far
east as possible.
So this way, I can
just follow the wind
and come into the island.
- Was there any point where
you had some question?
Or were you always like,
no, I think I'm right here.
- You should tell
the rainbow story.
- Huh?
- The rainbow-- can
I tell it for you?
OK, I have to tell it for him.
He doesn't like to brag.
So what was this thing about
the 2:30 in the morning where
he knew exactly where he was.
And he sailed-- we ended up
sailing a little bit too far
to the east.
So when the sun
rose, you couldn't
see anything, the island.
But he was sure that Aur
was to the east of it.
And so we started
to get the tow,
his crew was, like,
how do you know?
He said, well, we're heading
towards that rainbow.
There was a rainbow,
because there was a storm.
So we're heading
right towards our Aur.
And sure enough, just a
little while after that,
it started to pop out.
The other one, which I'll also
say just to give you some cred,
was on the way back it was
slower because the wind kind
of dropped out.
And there was this
concern about the current.
So he wanted to get some sleep.
Now, this is where,
unfortunately, the watch comes
into it, but what the hell.
So he was sleeping.
He said, wake me up--
to the crew, wake me up.
We're going to find Majuro.
We're going to see
Majuro somewhere
between 9:30 and 10:00.
And so they let him sleep
a little bit too long.
And it was 9:50.
And he gets up, and
he says, hey, we
should see Majuro, right?
And then one of the crew
looks up, and says, oh yeah,
there it is.
And it was exactly the time
that they found landfall.
So whatever he's
doing, it works.
- I think Alson is
evading your question
with a humbleness that is
distinctly Marshallese right
now, yes.
- So I have to talk for him.
- I keep saying [MARSHALLESE],,
which means guessing.
- Good guessing.
- So I'm curious about
a few of the choices
that you all made, because
I'm not from New England.
So these are
questions that I don't
have from the inherent
knowledge that many people here
have about sailing.
And so you all chose to go
south up to Aur, as opposed to--
or excuse me, north up to Aur,
as opposed to [INAUDIBLE],,
or is it [INAUDIBLE]
that's south.
Or why didn't you go east west?
Or why did you go north first?
Like those questions,
and you said both times
you left in the evening.
Was there a purpose for that?
Or was it a personal choice?
And then also
about the supplies,
I saw the rice and the coffee.
Did the weight of that
factor into your trip or not?
Yeah.
- The rationale for
going more south,
why going in the evening.
- I think the
decision to go out--
because we live on Majuro, so
we were just going up north
to Aur.
But the reason for going
in the evening was--
so, one of the reasons was
we want to, when we get up,
we see Aur.
But the plan was,
we were supposed
to wait a little
bit on the island
at the mouth of the channel.
But when we went out,
we enjoy the trip
too much that we just
continue, and go, and just
start going out to Aur.
That wasn't part of the plan.
So it's just because we
went a little bit early,
we changed the course
a bit toward the east.
- I'll just add on--
so these canoes,
they're not tacking canoes.
They're actually
called shantung canoes.
So to change direction, you
have to pick up the sail,
and walk it down the length
of the hull, and put it in.
So it actually can be quite
dangerous on the open ocean
to shunt the canoe,
to change direction.
So because the winds were
coming from the east,
it was basically a
straight shot north.
And there would be no
need to actually do
that maneuver on the ocean.
That was part of the strategy
of going straight north.
And then all that food, that
was on the escort vessel.
So they had like a
couple of bags of food,
but we had a couple
hundred pounds of stuff
in the bottom of our
escort vessel, yeah.
- Thank you.
Alson, I'm wondering if you
could explain or translate
the chant that you started with?
And does it have
any significance
about the navigational process?
- It's actually a chant
that we do when we sail.
So it's-- the first is
actually two chants.
[MARSHALLESE]
That chant is actually--
it's a spirit.
So when we're actually
welcoming the spirit
to be part of the crew.
And the other chant is
to speed up the canoe.
So [MARSHALLESE] is the
outrigger to balance the cue.
[MARSHALLESE] is the baler
to bail out any problems
that you face as you go out.
[MARSHALLESE] is when
you go, the [MARSHALLESE]
is the top top part
of the sail, the mast.
So you actually look forward.
So when you set your course,
and you kind of [INAUDIBLE]..
[MARSHALLESE] is the
bow of the canoe.
So you point the canoe into that
course that you already set.
[MARSHALLESE] means
that you work together,
and you aim, and everything
will be as fast as when
the lightning strike.
So it's kind of like a spiritual
chant to push the canoe faster.
And that's in the
olden days, everything
is all spirits, and chanting.
- OK, one more
one more question.
- Just technical, Joe said
they're shunting canoes.
And so I'm wondering,
what do you use to steer?
Is it a rudder, an oar?
- We actually have two
paddles, big use paddles.
And one guy would steer
with a big paddle,
is called [MARSHALLESE].
But there is also smaller
helper, smaller paddle to help.
So [MARSHALLESE],,
which literally
mean the small helper.
So these paddles
actually have the rope
that ties to the
middle of the canoe.
So they will still
be just part of the--
they won't go anywhere.
But when you shunt, then
you throw them in the water.
And then because when
you shunt, the canoe
actually move direction.
And the paddle will
drift automatically
to the other side.
But when you shunt in the
ocean, because you're going up
and down, the sail actually--
the guy would go to the
front, and pick up the sail.
And then when the canoe go down,
the sail is kind of in the air,
because it's so heavy.
So all you do is you actually
just guiding the sail,
because when you go down, a
couple of guys in the back
actually hold onto the rope,
because the masts go like this.
So there's a rope.
So they kind of pushed.
And the sail actually
automatically just kind of
fly over to the other side.
And it's amazing,
because these sails,
it takes about five or six
guys to put it on the canoe,
and set it up.
But when it's shunting in
the middle of the ocean,
it's easier to shunt in
the middle of the ocean.
But you have to know
what you're doing,
otherwise it's dangerous.
And it's-- we were talking
about belly button.
And, again, that's how
you measure the rope.
When you take the
rope that actually
secures the sail to the sail
step, you bring up the rope.
And you put it to
your belly button.
And then you go down, and
you kind of temporary lash.
So when you bring the rope,
the sail, to the side,
it won't go all the way out.
It just stop.
And whoever came up with the
measure with the belly button,
actually I've done
it many times.
- There's somebody there.
I guess this will
be the last one.
- OK.
I have a question for you.
Thank you very much, by the way.
This was a wonderful
presentation.
I guess this question
is for Joe and Alson.
And it's about language.
So I think this
presentation has done
a wonderful job of
helping us navigate
between the cognitivist and
the experiential kind of models
of knowledge, and also showing
that those boundaries are
quite blurry, in fact.
And on the one
hand, there's sort
of the mathematics
of the matter,
and there's the sort of stomach
feeling on the other hand.
But I'm wondering about
this in between stuff
to do with language, and words
like swell, or [INAUDIBLE]..
And maybe this is a question
to start with you, Joe,
about how do you use language
to sort of try to commensurate,
or not, these different
kinds of knowledge systems?
And what are the limits of that?
What are the affordances?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So in terms of language, I
mean for myself as an outsider,
just the raw aspect
of trying to learn
Marshallese in the first
place was challenging.
But once I got to a
certain level of fluency,
I could start to inquire
a little bit more
about those meanings, and
about what they represent,
and all the different
parts of that.
I guess what's interesting
about this particular domain
of navigation in the
Marshall Islands is
that there is an extremely--
there's a lot of older
terminology that seems
to be from a long time ago.
But in terms of
practical language
today, the number of
Marshallese terms that
have to do with waves
and swells and currents
is really, really limited.
I could probably count
less than 10 terms
that have to do with feelings
of like either roll, or pitch.
It's very, very limited.
And so in practice, like
talking with people like Captain
Korent, whether
it was talk story,
interviewing, or just
being on the canoe just
being with him when he
was looking at the waves,
most of it was not in an
articulate explanation.
I mean, we tried to do
that as much as possible.
But, really, for him it was
just like, look, there it is.
And it was, really,
like it was--
he didn't have--
there weren't there
weren't descriptions to
say like, well, there's
a certain shape of a wave.
And that's what you
need to be feeling.
And you're going to
feel this certain thing.
There was nothing
ever like that.
So it was more a
very minimal amount
of language to gain access.
And it was more just our
ability, both Alson and mine--
in the beginning, this
was going back 10 years--
basically trying to feel
what he was pointing out,
and somehow internalizing
that feeling,
but not being able
to articulate it.
But then you get into
the actual terminology,
there was a lot of overlap.
And sometimes, there might be
a Marshallese word for wave,
which could also mean current.
And sometimes that could
also refer to a swell.
And so sometimes,
the language itself
will get very convoluted.
And it was very frustrating
for me trying to be very like,
OK, we have to know
what this term means.
And a lot of times, it was
just very interchangeable.
Do you want to speak
to that at all?
- Well, I could say that there's
two words that I actually
repeated all the time.
There, you feel it.
So that's-- like Joe
said, it's very limited.
So I had the opportunity
to sail with Captain
Korent in a few voyages.
And he doesn't really talk.
he just say, there
you see it, there.
You feel it?
OK.
So that was kind of
like communication
go back and forth.
And I think it's
much the experience.
I think that's
what the focus was.
- OK, so thank you.